okay now part three is really crazy
tricky I'm gonna walk you through that
step by step but part two I reckon you
guys can help me work out their
trajectory through it and then do all
the working yourself without my help
let's read the question and then we're
going to work out what to do with it an
overhead power cable obstructs the
ship's exit from the wharf now some good
Town Planning the ship can only leave if
the water depth at the wharf is 8.5
meters or less so here is the water
depth at the wharf I should actually now
draw it maybe now you can do with me a
more accurate drawing of this because
that was just my random cosine function
and in fact because of this vertical
shift I know that I'm actually moved up
and down so why don't you draw for me
here huh what is this thing going to
look like well if I go from 4 up to 10
and I started high tired it is going to
be this shape but it's going to be
higher like that that looks okay that
looks okay all right so this is what it
looks like so you can see we can't leave
the wharf immediately do you see that I
can't leave the water level is too high
I'm gonna hit that overhead power cable
okay so I have to wait to some point and
then it'll be safe to go okay when do I
want to wait until have a look what does
it say I want the water depth to not be
10 not be 9 I want it to be 8.5 okay so
you can actually put it doesn't have to
be super accurate but enough so that you
can see it on the graph my 8.5 looks
like it's somewhere around there I'd say
he says with scientific precision so if
that's where 8.5 is you can see there
are a couple of times when the graph
hits 8.5 but I want that have a look at
the wedding
I want the earliest time that I can go
right so I want to find out when that
time is and that will give me a result
okay T T is a time unit what kind of
time unit is it it's going to be hours
of some kind so T is going to be equal
to a number and you're going to have to
translate that into not a number of
hours but a time on the clock they
actually give it to you four or five
so I'm going to pause there and see if
that's enough information for you guys
to try and go through the working if you
think you're on the right track call me
over but you do know the answer you're
supposed to get to so see if you can get
there on your own let's bring it back
together so you can see I haven't
written all of the working here because
I think most of it's quite trivial and
you guys can handle it if you want the
full thing it's right here and I can
show it to you afterwards but I've just
put in the key steps this is a two-month
question some of you have asked are
where with the marks babe okay now
please note they've given you the final
answer already so we get nothing for
writing four or five a.m. at the bottom
okay all the marks are on what were the
things that show the 4 or 5 a.m. is the
actual answer so I've put in what I
think of the main act is one last thing
I want to write so firstly have a look
here I'm solving for when Y that's the
water depth at the wharf is equal to
this safe depth 8.5 okay it takes a
little bit of monkeying around with the
numbers it's really just arithmetic to
get to here and then you either have to
solve for for piety on 25 so you need
cos inverse okay I put this in here I
think it's a a nice touch you don't have
to have it but it's handy okay we have
an infinite number of solutions for this
but I don't want any of the solutions
I want the earliest solution that's what
the question says show that the earliest
possible time is that an adult right so
I've said well the first time that
cosine has a solution there is PI on
three that's the first time it hits a
half so once I do that again there's a
bit of manipulation of the fractions and
so on this is what I get to okay now I
think probably the last thing that's
important is to interpret what this
means T is the number of hours after
high tide so therefore it is say two
hours and what is it 12th of an L five
minutes which gives me my four or five
a.m. so this is after high tide at two
and then I would say well that's four or
five just like your question said okay
there it is three marks happy times